sono artista mutage planario
e anche una stratega culturale vi voglio
parlare di queste due
late del mio percorso creativo
anche
devo chiedere Perdona simile italiano
non è perfetto e la terza lingua
Quindi se esce un po' di inglese
spagnolo
è per questo ma è una cosa interessante
di parlare altri idioma perché c'è esce
qualche obsolezione
come per esempio con questa parola
stratega
sembra a me come strega
Eh ho pensato Forse è giusto anche
perché lavoro un po' con la magia la
cosa che amo Lo che faccio
il lavoro che faccio
icone l'amore
le cose diventa un po' come la magia
non sempre c'è momenti che no amo ma
veramente è l'amore è un ingrediente
centrale
per fare il latte
e anche per fare altro lavoro che faccio
è coltivare spazi oppure luoghi di
incontro
questo fatto in San Francisco sono nato
in Germania ma ho vissuto 20 anni a San
Francisco
e là ho fondato un spazio un piccolo
centro di arte che si chiama Red Paper
House per 20 anni stavo veramente la
stessa indagine
provando di capire come dei creare un
spazio che quando una persona entra che
la persona sente a suo agio
che quando c'è molti persone
e persone
rari siti di diversi
che possono essere e nello stesso
luogo
in tutti può sentire al suo agio
questo era sempre la domanda che
continuava a ricercare
voglio parlare un po' di anche mia
pratica
dipingere e anche ce l'ho un video di
questo perché tutti queste due strade va
insieme
io quando faccio una pittura un quadro
non so
che cosa
arriva non c'era un immagine
la cosa che faccio è che provo di
lasciare la mente completa anche vuota
Chiara
è presente e non prendo di essere come
un maestro delle materiale ma un più uno
studente
perché quando ho messo le meteriale
sempre i miei palla
è un conversazione
quindi devo scottare che dici che dice
la materiale
i piano piano così dialogo
una cosa immerge quindi voglio
presentare un piccolo video un po' di
più dei tre minuti
potete sentire un po' da questi processo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sto facendo una cosa
sapete che
Sto ascoltando a voi
voi siete ascoltando a me
Quindi io sto stavo
scottando a voi ascoltando a me
ascoltandola a voi
è un circolo
una cosa dell'energia
lo faccio perché questo è quello che
faccio quando faccio un dipinto quando
dipingere
e questa è capacita di
sentire di ascoltare
senza una necessità
per una risposta come lasciare andare
nella energia
di ascoltare
soprattutto me fa pensare nel mondo che
dove siamo con tanto
informazione
tutti stanno parlando parlando parlando
già ho detto la parola amore E come
amore diventa con un po' di magia
anche quella queste spazio queste
dinamica ascoltare ed ascoltare le
Ascolta
crea
intimità
no
cioè quando Io ascolto a voi
arrivo a un po' di più Decimo
c'è un po' di più intimità
e pensi che la intimità sempre
è una cosa che pensiamo è una cosa
privata
perché non me la lente di momenti intimi
sono con pochi persone
un piccolo spazio
ma voglio dire che anche è un è uno
spazio dentro tra noi
quando possiamo
e sta storia
nostra Aggio
rilassato
aperto
e con quella spazio se la possibilità
che è una cosa nuova arriva una cosa
vivente una cosa spontanea
Questo è il processo che uso per fare un
quadro e anche un processo che uso
provando di creare un spazio un luogo di
incontro
questo fatto ho detto in San Francisco
quando sono arrivato qui a Abruzzo è la
cosa che
ho iniziato in Pontecchio perché sono
arrivato a Pontecchio dopo Abruzzo
è un a lungo è una storia più lungo per
spiegare come
questo successo
ma ho deciso di creare un aereo
aeroporto
è un borgo dei 300 abitanti No il
Fontecchio intronation Airport
perché è un aeroporto È un luogo di
incontro No perché gente arriva de tutti
parte del mondo
e tutti sono diversi
Quindi è un po' di
che lavoro ovviamente c'è anche un sacco
di cosa logistica
Ma la cosa fondamentale
e la analgia che portiamo la cosa che io
porto dentro da me
e che la cosa
può cambiare come quella quel quadro
Cambia Cambia Cambia si lasciamo spazio
per una cosa
sviluppare organicamente
prendete una pausa
a pensare
ricorrere un momento e la vostra vita
un momento molto intima un momento di
magia forse
al momento
che sicuramente credo che non era un
momento che hai pianificato
non è che Ok Voglio fare un piano per
avere questa esperienza
de magia spontanea
Perché non è una cosa che possiamo
controllare
e quindi
la cosa centrale che voglio condividere
oggi
oggi è questa questa sensazione questa
apprezzo
per le cose che sono più intangibile
e amore che diventa magia Ascolta che
diventa colazione che diventa intimità
sapere
una cosa Per esempio io ho pensato
questa mattina come funziona quando
quando stai seduto in una sedia gli do
dopo Poi ti alzi
e la sedia rimane un po' caldo no
è l'amore è così non è dire che
richiede il tuo seduto è più
che quando tocchiamo qualsiasi cosa con
amore
quell'amore rimane un po' un piccolo
periodo di tempo è ovvio Quando facciamo
questo con persone ma anche con
qualsiasi oggetto quando cuciamo
quando sto cucinando
gli do amore
entra nel cibo Se una persona sta
coltivando curando un giardino
nell'amore entra nel giardino e la gente
sa possiamo sentire quella cosa
è una pratica
di imparare Come rimanere
chi è
questo su palco
quando non sa che dire non stai sicuro
e avere fiducia
che noi siamo come i pianti fiori alberi
che tiene la vita dentro che sa che fa
quindi
dico questo perché uso questo è la
pratica creativa
ogni volta prendere più fiducia
stai aperto
rilassato ascoltando
e quando ascoltiamo altri persone le
altre persone diventa più rilassata
perché diventa visibile e tiene uno
spazio nella stanza perché c'è una
persona che l'ha apprezziations
quindi
Penso di lasciare così
e possiamo
provare insieme
posso lasciare
questa cosa nel mente ma senza un
pensiero perché quando stai Quando sto
ascoltando devo essere senza pensiero
c'è un limite
del pensiero
e Limite e che il pensiero non può
entrare nell'ascoltavera
ok Quindi per finire facciamo insieme Io
ascolto a voi Voi
ascoltate a me
ascoltandola ascoltandola
va bene
è un account in streaming
è un po' John
Ma grazie
[Applauso]